when I was a graduate student I had no
real conception of the time scale
involved in math research for me in
everything I've done it's been very slow
you get into a feel takes a long time to
learn what's the what's going on long
time to figure out what you should be
working on a long time to solve it and
then sometimes at that point you you
understand things a bit better you
realize well that wasn't the right thing
to have been working on so for me that
that time scale has been five to ten
years in the things I've done and I just
had no conception of that both at length
of time when I was a graduate student my
working sounds very collaborative
I've had many co-authors and I've work
with them for a long time for me there
are two really important aspects of that
one is that in a group usually someone
has an idea so it has much more of a
sense of continuous progress and when
you're by yourself and very often you're
you have longer periods of being stuck
by yourself the second which I think is
more important if then is the social
aspect when you're doing math by
yourself it can be very isolating and
when you work in a group it turns that
individual activity into something
that's much more social and pleasant and
human so for me that aspect has been
really important to my career